judge refuses to accept Hunter
Brighton's plea deal after initial
grooming falls apart in court this is an
Insider story Hunter Biden's attempt
guilty plea to two tax crime charges
fails as the judge raises concerns about
the agreement scope and potential
immunity from future prosecutions uh
related to business dealings the plea
agreement was null and void after
questions arose in Delaware Federal
Court prosecutors accused Biden of
illegally avoiding taxes in 2017 and 18
with him reportedly owing around 1.2
million dollars which he later Paid in
Full the revised plea agreement covers
2014-2019 focusing on tax offenses drug
uses and gun possession do U.S District
Judge Marilyn Noriega and appointee of
former president Donald Trump declined
to accept the plea deal and express
concerns about the scope of the charges
leaving The Plea on hold as the case
unfolds so uh Tom are you following the
story closely or no uh as close as close
as I want to Vinny
well Rob Rob has a video pack and that
I'll show after this but
don't realize is what
is we'll have today one of Hunter
Biden's uh lawyers contacted the court
clerk's office falsely claiming to be
part of the house Ways and Means legal
team and asked the clerk to pull the
adverse filings of technical reasons so
they were doing like some trickery and
they got caught the court figured out
what happened and demanded answers from
hunting's pretty wow dude Pat that you
should be this bored as a lawyer you're
calling pretending to be somebody else
anyway they got caught uh and I think
they should be this boy but Pat here's a
question I I saw this live this is
Hunter Biden uh a private citizen I
don't give a [__] who Sonny is he's
showing up to the courthouse and a
six-car secret service Convoy detail
with other like 20 other Secret Service
Pat show this and then tell me who's
paying for this look at this this is not
the president this is the president's
son look at this protection bro
and look how you see all the Secret
Service on the right yeah of course
that's that's the lead the lead vehicle
has to stop they have to go there for
for for just in case somebody wants to
do something crazy they give the okay
you would think the president of the
United States is coming out of the
vehicle right you guys are all paying
for this look at this and you talked
about Mr Untouchable that's him right
there Untouchable going into court and
nothing's gonna happen to him well his
lawyers are calling the clerk Adam
that's all dude you know how illegal
that is what they just did and nothing's
gonna happen but but here's the part
about why what if you're a conservative
and you hate Donald Trump because you're
a rhino or you're a DeSantis guy or
whatever you are
if there's anything you have to know
that why this screws it up for Hunter
and people like that out of all the
states that you could have chosen to
appoint
a U.S District Judge Trump appoints
Judge Marilyn Noriega in Delaware out of
all the states you don't think he knew
eventually something could happen that
this judge is going to come back and
help him out I don't know I think I
think these are the types of things that
you realize the if there's anything we
learned in 2016 the election he flipped
three seeds that's what led to Roe v
Wade that's what led to a lot of these
other tax things that they couldn't do
that's what led to them wanting to make
the election all based on uh what he
called it um uh who gets the most votes
rather than electoral popular vote they
want to do the popular vote that's what
they wanted to change if they had it
they would have changed that they would
have changed so many different things
and these judges so you know love it or
hate the guy the guy appointed some
judges that are now backfiring on the
people to say Hey you thought you were
going to get full-on Immunity on
additional thing that's going on uh-uh
that's not gonna fly with us we're going
to eventually actually see what's going
on here by the way for another person
similar to the offense that Hunter Biden
has that person went to jail for five
years under this judge same exact job
same exact crime same exact crime five
years yes go ahead all right by the way
um fully appreciate what you're saying
about the judges we talked about that in
2020 when when during the election and
everything with that
um
here's the way I see this I mean we can
have the whole Hunter Biden discussion
you know he should have registered with
the barisma as registered as a foreign
agent and the foreign agent uh
Resolution Act and he got paid 8 million
bucks and barisma and all that nonsense
um he's facing what he's facing I think
that the maximum sentence right here by
the way specification is going on five
years five years maximum sentence is 12
months in prison apparently and 25 000
for each account it's according to the
Wall Street Journal
um
I would argue the macro perspective here
okay because ultimately if Joe Biden
loses the election nobody's gonna ever
say the name Hunter Biden again who
gives a [__] nobody will it's over like
the whole thing is
comes down to
at this point the economy is doing
better we address that on a play months
down inflation's doing okay we'll see
where the stock market is in terms of
election
I would argue that Hunter Biden is Joe
Biden's number one political liability
at this point I agree he's a [__]
liability okay you think so you know
they everyone made the the joke that Joe
Biden was uh hiding in the basement
during 2020 I wouldn't be surprised if
Hunter Biden goes on a little vacation
uh come election season and everything
will be whether it's dismissed whether
there's a um whether they there's a plea
deal whatever
he's wanted to do everything he can to
get this over and done with by the time
2024 starts and that's a political
liability Kamala Harris is his vice
president
exactly but but
Adam and I I get what you're saying it's
the accountability of and it's not dude
to be ask you I can give two shits about
Hunter he's the luckiest dumbest
crackhead on the planet it's all the
stuff that those laptops have about him
the big guy the text his father is
implicated with everything with Russia
with Ukraine everything and guess what
we're sending all this money to Ukraine
because it's almost like they have all
this dirt on him and they're like listen
keep the billions coming or like Pat
said with the video with that ogre
billionaire we're going to expose all
the [__] that you did so zelinski is
like keep the money coming keep the
flags going and I'm not there why
wouldn't you be like the whole Ukraine
war is not a whole War because at the
end of the day it's a NATO situation 100
macroeconomic Russia that's a whole
conversation then eight million dollars
with purism no not eight eight million
dollars no what I'm saying is the
president is compromised if the
president's compromised through all this
information on the laptop it's not just
Barista it's China China it's oh it's
all the this stuff Adam it's his son's
dumbass exposed the father but again
we're going with the Untouchables you
can't touch these people bro they're in
and when you have the FBI and the doj in
your back pocket you're good bro you can
get away with literally murder the whole
procedural side here is what really
stinks I mean yesterday yesterday
I was reading this is the part I dug
into that I really didn't want to but it
caught my eye and I dug into it while
his lawyers his Hunter his lawyers are
in there and trying to put together this
plea deal and the judge is asking the
prosecutors have you completed all of
your investigations and they said no and
she asked have you completed the Foreign
Corrupt individuals investigation
they're like no we haven't and then
she's saying well then how can we agree
to a plea deal on this charge with the
gun and on this charge here how can you
agree to a plea deal if there's still
investigation ongoing and not all of the
charges are here that you're going to
play out on you have to complete the
investigation to say the investigation
is completed and there's these five
charges okay bottom two cancel the
middle one top two you gotta take guilty
and then we'll give you the and we'll do
the fine and we'll do the sentencing
like here are you guys in agreement
that's how plea deals work in judges
Chambers so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign